the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC
much is being made particularly by
right-wing media about an utterance that
President Joe Biden made yesterday which
some are saying is a sign that he is not
planning to run for re-election in 2024.
now there's been a lot of attention on
the Republican side over the last
several weeks the reason for that
attention has been that failed former
president Donald Trump announced he's
running again despite that Ron DeSantis
the recently re-elected governor of
Florida is polling really well even
though he hasn't actually announced that
he's running for anything the Republican
Civil War Etc so there have been a lot
of reasons why the focus has been on the
Republican side but there's another
element to this which is that the
suspicion that Joe Biden is not really
interested in running for re-election
has been to some degree supplanted by
the growing belief that Joe Biden will
run for re-election and polling that
looks pretty okay for Joe Biden and
suddenly headlines like this one
appeared yesterday
for example in the right-leaning
Washington examiner I don't know about
that Biden casts doubt on 2024 run so so
what exactly happened well let's just
look at the video what you are going to
see here is Joe Biden delivering a
statement at the White House a tribal
Nation Summit and as he is wrapping up
someone from the crowd seems to shout
out four more years and Joe Biden seems
to respond I don't know about that
that's the best assessment that we have
although it's not totally clear let's
take a look at it and then discuss
as my grandfather training him and say
that's the Irish of it thank you all
very much
okay four more years I don't know about
that
so is that what was said it seems to be
I mean I think I heard four more years
and then I don't know about that let's
listen to it one more time I think it
would say that's the Irish of it thank
you all very much
thanks oh I don't know about that
is too much being made of this I think
so I don't have any special insight into
whether Joe Biden is or isn't going to
run if you had asked me nine months ago
I would have said I think Joe Biden is
definitely not running for re-election
today I think it's much more likely that
he will run for re-election and part of
this has to do with legislative
achievements uh approval rating recovery
circumstantial elements to this there's
a lot of different reasons but I'm
separating my opinion from what we saw
there I think it is just as likely
as what Joe Biden meant was
this isn't the venue in which we're
going to talk about my campaign because
we're here for the tribal Nation Summit
that would be consistent with Joe
Biden's personality and his kind of
modus operandi
um I think it's just as likely that it's
that as it is Joe Biden saying I don't
know that I'm going to be running and in
fact when you really think about it is
it likely that Joe Biden would let slip
arguably for the first time in a more
formal capacity that he might not run in
response to an utterance from the crowd
at an event about something completely
different I don't think so if Joe Biden
is going to tell us I don't know that
I'm running in 24 I don't think it's
going to be in a venue like this in
reaction to something yelled out from
the crowd now when it comes to the
polling question it is interesting to
take a look at some of the relatively
new polling that we have seen
um for 2024 these are of course
hypothetical polls and it's really a
pretty mixed bag here you see that an
Emerson College poll that's an A minus
rated pollster has it as Biden DeSantis
DeSantis plus four but in Biden versus
trump it has it even uh on the other
hand you look at the Marquette
University law school poll also that's
an A B rated pollster pretty good they
have Biden even with DeSantis
um in one poll
um DeSantis slightly ahead in a
different poll and then Biden well ahead
of Donald Trump and then you go back to
a premise poll not a rated pollster at
all they have DeSantis plus four over
Biden but Biden plus six over Trump so
the gist of the polling right now
contains two pieces of important data
number one against Trump Biden seems to
pull pretty well
and against DeSantis Biden polls less
well that's the trend and depending on
which poll you look at the specific
numbers differ
we are going to have to wait and see I
don't know what Biden heard in the
moment I don't a hundred percent know
what Biden said
but I don't believe Biden would reveal
possibly not running in that sort of
venue and in that sort of format well
ladies and gentlemen we got him the IRS
has released Donald Trump's tax returns
in fact six years worth of tax returns
to the house committee that is involved
in that investigation it has taken three
years but it has finally happened and
now this becomes a matter of watching
for leaks and of course I would never
tell anyone to leak anything or to
disclose sensitive information or to do
anything wrong I would just never do
that but I also understand from an
objective standpoint that the
possibility of a leak here is
significant and we are going to be
watching for that CNBC reports IRS gives
Trump tax returns to house committee
after three-year legal battle the final
straw was the Supreme Court saying we're
not going to block the release of these
tax returns the article points out the
house Ways and Means Committee has
obtained years worth of federal income
tax returns for former president Donald
Trump just a week after the Supreme
Court rejected his effort to block that
democratic-controlled panel from getting
those records from the IRS the committee
has been seek had been seeking Trump's
tax return since 2019 when he was still
president Trump broke Decades of
tradition by refusing to publicly
release his tax returns now remember
that for a very long time Trump was
insisting as soon as my audits are done
and
I'm going to go ahead and release
everything and the goal posts kept
moving and moving and moving here's just
a little bit of a reminder of that this
is more recent it says you just said you
spoke to your accountant about
potentially releasing your taxes did he
tell you when you can release them do
you how big is the owner deadline for
when you're going to release it I get
married worse than the Tea Party got
traded because I have a lot of people in
there deep down in the IRS they treat me
horribly we made a deal it was all
settled until I decide to run for
president
I get treated very badly by the IRS very
unfairly but we had a deal all done as
soon as we're completed with the deal I
want to release it but says you just
said you spoke yeah uh he didn't really
intend to release those tax returns and
quite frankly once it became clear that
his followers didn't really care I
understand why he didn't release them
and we'll get in a moment to what we
believe would be in there a few other
notes here from the CNBC
um report a treasury Department
spokesperson told NBC News quote
treasury has complied with last week's
Court decision the treasury Department
is the parent of the IRS the Ways and
Means Committee has said it wanted
copies of Trump's tax returns and the
tax returns of trump legal entities for
an inquiry into how the IRS audits
presidential tax returns by law the tax
agency audits the returns of a sitting
president every year so it's a leak
watch now what is most likely in those
town tax returns I we've been building
and sort of tweaking our belief about
this based on what has become publicly
available information over time I think
the most likely Revelations from Trump's
taxes would all be things that we
suspect or to some degree know already
number one Trump is not as rich as he
claims to be
it's hard to imagine Trump being richer
than he claims to be and based on what
people like Michael Cohen and others
have told us Donald Trump has postured
to be higher on the Forbes richest list
using all sorts of different methods and
more than likely his taxes would show
he's not actually as rich as he has
claimed to be number two Trump lies and
that we know we know Trump lies he's the
most dishonest president in the modern
political era number three Trump
probably has debts that we might call
sketchier debts shadier debts to
entities or individuals that he likely
would not want us to know and which may
potentially present a national security
risk even greater than that which we
already believe based on publicly
available information and I think that
that would be the uh those would be the
main Revelations from Donald Trump's tax
returns now one interesting other note I
want to mention Donald Trump as you know
exhausted just about every he exhausted
did every means available to him to try
to block the release of these tax
returns including going to the Supreme
Court and It ultimately did not work now
we can colloquially say
would someone who has nothing to hide
work this hard to hide their tax returns
well I don't know a lot of it could just
be ego Trump doesn't want the world to
know beyond any doubt that he's not as
rich as he claims to be but one of the
arguments that through his lawyers
Donald Trump made to the Supreme Court
was that no Congress has ever wielded
its legislative powers to demand a
president's tax returns and that
continues to be a theme this has no
president has ever had his home raided
by the FBI Trump said that after the
search warrant was executed in
Mar-A-Lago these things haven't happened
before because we've never needed to see
them happen before Donald Trump Donald
Trump so flouted the Norms of the
presidency that when you get
unprecedented inputs you end up with
unprecedented outputs outputs and it's
really that simple
um do Republicans even care I don't
think so I don't know that they ever
really cared if they care shared they
might not have voted for Donald Trump to
begin with when he didn't release his
tax returns and made it clear he didn't
really plan to and the audit story was
completely made up so the house Ways and
Means Committee has Trump's taxes six
years worth we now will wait very
patiently to see out of genuine
curiosity whether those tax returns leak
we're going to take a very quick break
and be back right after this
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
last week we reported to you that a
speaker of the house Nancy Pelosi would
be stepping down from leadership of the
democratic party Democrats of course
poised to become the minority Party in
the House of Representatives based on
the November 8th election results in the
2022 midterms Nancy Pelosi stepping down
but will stay in congress and Democrats
have now decided that it is Hakeem
Jeffries a former guest of this program
who will become minority leader for
Democrats in the House of
Representatives the New York Times
reporting in a show of Unity House
Democrats elect Hakeem Jeffries minority
leader a new Trio including
Representatives Catherine Clark of
Massachusetts as number two and Pete
Aguilar of California as number three
will take the reins in January replacing
speaker Nancy Pelosi and her team
um Jeffries is 52 years old Clark is 59
and Aguilar is 43
certainly moving in the direction of
younger which is something that many
Democrats have been calling for now it
shouldn't surprise anyone if you've been
following American politics for any
period of time
to know that the right is immediately
Framing and attacking Hakeem Jeffries as
some kind of extreme radical of course
the reality is that he is nothing of the
sort and I would encourage you if you
really just want to see the way that he
presents himself and talks about issues
and thinks through issues check out my
interview with Hakeem Jeffries from some
years ago the topics will be less
relevant to 2022 but it is of course
still the same Hakeem Jeffries here is
Newsmax with a commentary on Hakeem
Jeffries they are saying much of the
decision was motivated simply by race
and the fact that Hakeem Jeffries is not
white and they say a lot of the exact
things that we would expect but it's
important to remember they would be
saying this no matter who was chosen all
right other news tonight uh Democrats
picked to replace Nancy Pelosi indicates
that their party has no intention of
veering away from the squad's favorite
brand of politics Hakeem Jeffries
is an anti-us oil rabid defender of the
pro-abortion death cult he's an election
denier
he's a pretty radical New York
congressman
he tweeted numerous times following the
2016 election at one point writing the
more we learn about the 2016 election
the more illegitimate it becomes now you
need to understand they love to play
this game so first of all some of the
things that that this Newsmax host says
well he's part of the pro-abort pro pro
death machine abortion whatever
he like most Americans supports abortion
rights that's not super controversial
but everything has to be framed as
completely outrageous on Newsmax when
you are perpetuating this brand of fear
and outrage politics that has completely
supplanted policy for the American right
wing this issue of election denier you
know when people on the left questioned
the legitimacy of Trump's presidency
they were not literally saying it was
stolen in the way that Trump has said
about 2020 there were sort of two
meanings to Trump as illegitimate as
president one meaning was that Trump
Rose to the presidency on the shoulders
of foreign support from Russia and of
course that's been demonstrated now of
course it has not been demonstrated that
Trump and Putin got together and ate
Frog's legs while plotting exactly how
Putin would do it but we know
Russia had a preference for Trump over
Hillary and used social media and other
influence Avenues to try to make it so
that Trump would win and not Hillary
Clinton it's not do the election over
its people were swayed by Propaganda
that came from a foreign adversary okay
very very different and then number two
uh Trump was illegitimate in the
colloquial sense in that he had no
business being president of the United
States had no idea what was going on
didn't know up from down was completely
clueless it is not fair to say that
those are election deniers in the way
that people are going around like
Marjorie Taylor green literally saying
oh more people actually tried to vote
for Trump but Joe Biden manipulated the
machines or whatever the case may be not
even remotely comparable and it's
important to understand that when they
pull that line out let's listen to a
little bit more of this and now this man
leads leads the house Democrats so you
see the road that that party is going
down Republican strategist Aaron perini
joins me now to talk about this good to
see you Aaron it's a pretty radical
Choice I'm not surprised because you
knew it wasn't going to be a white guy I
think we all knew that but it's a very
extreme choice
it is an extreme choice and Democrats
like to use this adage right show me
your budget and I'll show you your
values well show me your leader and I'll
show you your party they have picked an
election denier you know the green New
Deal loving champion of Russian
disinformation Hakeem Jeffries to leave
and of course that's completely
inaccurate and there is really nothing
at all radical about Hakeem Jeffries I
think that Jeffries does have a very
difficult position and timing he is
entering leadership of the democratic
party as Democrats have lost control of
the house number one and number two as
Republicans are particularly
incentivized to make the next two years
about you know Hunter Biden and maybe
even Hillary Clinton's emails if you can
imagine so a difficult time to become
part of Democratic Leadership but an
interesting choice brilliant guy check
out his interview with me some years ago
you know one of the things about a cult
is that the cult leader will expect if
not demand
absolute and total sacrifice and loyalty
from the cult followers and failed
Arizona Republican gubernatorial
candidate Kerry lake is doing exactly
that she wants supporters who are
willing to go to jail for her the
delusions of grandeur are getting worse
and worse for Kerry Lake here she is
saying these listen you should be
willing to go and sit in jail that for
the movement or whatever but really she
means for her check this out I wish that
somebody would say you know what arrest
me then I don't care we need people with
courage to say class what Felony go
ahead go for it arrest me because this
is a botched election and you're
disenfranchising tell me it's a felony
to be out here doing what I'm doing and
arrest me because Carrie Lake really won
even though she didn't the folks in
Mojave County when you allow this kind
of an election in Maricopa County to
stand
yeah I like this clip because it
confirms very openly and clearly what
we've suspected for a long time which is
that this is a cult you're willing to go
to jail for me right because I'm that
important to you has she offered them a
pardon on state charges when she's
installed as Governor as Donald Trump
demanded that she be on Truth Central in
the middle of the night earlier this
week like if she's really that confident
she's ultimately going to overturn this
why not make that offer when I finally
Ascend to the governorship I'm going to
Pardon every single one of you truly a
person with not a single redeeming
quality about her Carrie Lake she also
by the way did the globalist thing
and it's so tired at this point but here
she pulls that out as well saying it's
bigger than her that and this this is
another cult thing even though I need
you to go to jail for me it's really
bigger than me in this case it's about
the globalists we feel very confident in
our case and I have not given up one
centilla of the fight I have in me
somebody said Carrie you're fearless and
I said you know I guess I'm I'm fearless
right now in this difficult time because
what I fear most of all is what happens
if we don't step forward and act with
courage right now what we're left with
we will have a shell of our country we
look at what's happening in Brazil and
what's happening in China we'll be
looking a lot like China and I'm not
talking about the protests happening now
I'm talking about we'll be enslaved by a
globalist system if we don't stand up
right now this is our moment this is our
true moment right now in our history Now
understand that if you went to Kerry
Lake and said what exactly do you mean
by globalism and what are the parameters
of the globalist system
she probably couldn't answer maybe she'd
come up with some passing thing but she
wouldn't be able to really answer if you
go to Cary Lake supporters and many of
them are Trump supporters as well and
you ask them what is globalism what do
you what do you mean what by when you
talk about globalism and globalists if
you're lucky
they'll be able to Rattle off the names
of a few Jewish men
but they are not even understanding what
it is that is being fed to them so
reminder Carrie Lake didn't win Kerry
Lake will not be the governor of Arizona
don't send her any money if you want to
you know fool in their money or soon
parted it's all a scam she's she didn't
win and she's not going to be the
governor but now she's saying this is
about fighting globalists and you should
be willing to go to jail for me it is a
cult ladies and gentlemen former
president Mike Pence has been doing the
rounds uh mostly to sell his book and
maybe to kind of softly prod at the
possibility of a 2024 presidential run
and he appeared on a Fox news program
called outnumbered the gag
withoutnumbered is that it's for female
hosts and they invite on a man each show
and the man is outnumbered okay that's
the idea
check out so context this interview that
Pence gave is almost as bad as some of
Trump's worst interviews it's it's
really something to see check out how
Dynamic and funny and clever and
charismatic Mike Pence is right off the
bat and of course I'm kidding he's none
of those things hello everyone this is
outnumbered I'm Emily compagno and
joining me today Carly shimkus Martha
McCallum and Ainsley Earhart and we are
honored to have on the former Vice
President of the United States Mike
Pence it is his first time on
outnumbered and sir we are thrilled and
honored to have you here with us today
oh it's great to be here although I I do
feel
outnumbered
you know it's uh it's great to be here
Carly shimkus but I do feel
outnumbered
just Charisma dripping off of this guy
reeking of Charisma and of course we're
all cringing very very hard now there
were some interesting questions posed to
Pence more interesting was was the way
that he answered these questions he was
asked do you want to be the president of
the United States
lot of time so you know I think one of
the first ones I want to ask you is what
is on everyone's mind because this is a
foundation for people understanding you
and your life we often see books come
out from people who are saying I want to
be president of the United States so my
first question is do you want to be
president of the United States
well Martha I would say no more no less
than any other kid that grew up with a
cornfield in his backyard so is that a
yes or a no you know I can tell you the
dream of Public Service animated my
youth as I write about
uh in the book the opportunity I had to
represent my hometown in Congress to be
governor of Indiana and ultimately to
serve as your vice president it's deeply
humbling to me but Karen and I are going
to take time over the holidays you know
we have two in the military so we would
between deployments our our kids have
not all been back in Indiana uh for the
last three years together so we'll take
time to reflect deliberate talk to the
kids and uh we're gonna we're gonna make
a decision about what our next calling
is but I I promise to keep you posted
but when you do that when you yeah
um let me interpret this answer for you
in you know standard Republican speak
and to some degree politicians speak I
don't know if I'd have a shot at winning
right now Martha so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to bring in consultants and
pollsters to figure out do I have a shot
and if I do have a shot I'm gonna
probably try to go for it particularly
if I believe that even in losing it
might raise my profile or somehow be
advantageous to me in some way shape or
form now one of the things that is a
little bit different
is that as a former VP
it's one thing to lose the general
election for President as a former VP
happened to Al Gore for example but to
lose the Republican primary as a former
VP and in particular to run against the
president you served under that's a
little bit different and that I don't I
don't know has that happened in history
I don't know off the top of my head but
that's sort of a different thing in a
different different consideration a
couple other Clips here citing
absolutely no evidence whatsoever
uh he starts talking about how Twitter
and Elon Musk are being targeted by
Biden because of something related to
the hunter Biden story check this out
the suggestion that uh that the
president of the United States is
keeping a close eye
uh on on any element of of the media is
deeply offensive to me it's it's it's
your job in the media to keep a close
eye on elected officials I I lived in
that world for 20 years as a congressman
as a governor and as your vice president
and uh but I do think as you suggest I I
think it may well be uh because Elon
Musk who I came to know very well during
the four years of the Trump Pence
Administration
I think it's because he is preparing to
release information finally about the
suppression of the hunter Biden story
so this is like two layers of stuff
first of all there's no evidence that
anything that's going on has to do with
the hunter Biden story but again if all
you have is a hammer everything looks
like a nail must be related to Hunter
Biden that's number one but the funniest
and honestly the scariest part of this
is Pence saying you know a white house
keeping an eye on the media Trump had a
hit list of media people that he didn't
like Trump wanted to kick people out of
the press room Trump did kick some
people out of The Press Room like Jim
Acosta from CNN briefly although he
eventually went back he says it's
chilling or whatever phraseology he used
for an Administration to be keeping an
eye on the media the Trump
Administration was maybe the modern
Administration most adversarial and
hostile to journalism and to the media
and to a free press it's absolutely
Bonkers now one last clip here
I won't even introduce this one just
listen oh I want to ask you a question
about your faith because we share the
same faith but how do you know
that that is God calling you because
everywhere you go people love you how to
even Democrats love you because you're
just a nice wholesome good person who
does the right thing and uh and you're
honest you're honest but they might not
like your politics but they like who you
are in your character so I I love that
first of all everybody loves you
Democrats love you listen Democrats
don't love them and the Maga people
wanted them killed on January 6th so I
don't know what on Earth Ainsley Earhart
is talking about but I love the question
how do you know that that's God really
speaking to you it's sort of like one of
these things where Bush said he spoke to
God and God told him to invade Iraq and
then uh you know all these stories that
are told I I Chuck checked with God and
God said to go ahead and do it or God
chose this word was it maybe just
indigestion and God not really speaking
to you I just absolutely love that how
do you know it really is God speaking to
you and of course the question has its
own internal Logic for those who believe
God speaks to them
or might or speaks to some people
how do you know that that's really God
speaking to you is a very logical
question they never have an actual good
answer but it's it's just so funny to
hear Ainsley Earhart say how do you know
and also just everyone loves you no no
that's not true the Democrats don't love
him and half of the Republicans don't
love him and some of that half wanted
him killed on January 6th unbelievable
stuff and Penn seems to be in the
running for interviews as absurd as
those that we have seen from Donald
Trump will have all these Pence Clips on
our Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and remember
you've got to be subscribed on YouTube
subscribe to the David Pacman Show
YouTube channel if you watch the clips
but that subscribe button is enabled hit
that button it is free all you're saying
when you hit subscribe is I affirm the
David packman show you're not paying
anything
you're not committed to anything you're
just saying I affirm this I affirm the
content affirm away hit that subscribe
button we're going to take a quick break
and be back right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's great to Welcome to the program
today Adam Rogers who's a senior Tech
correspondent at Insider and also author
of the book full spectrum one of his
recent articles is going to be the uh
Catalyst for our conversation today
called sure Twitter and Facebook have
deepened polarization just not in the
way you think Adam really great having
you on today I appreciate your time oh
thanks for having me I appreciate it so
okay I mean let's let's kind of go right
to the punch line and then maybe we'll
work backwards from there so it's common
to think social media
has made polarization worse I think
there's a number of ways that people
would assume that that's the case filter
Bubbles and Echo Chambers probably is
one and you know we can kind of list
others what is the way in which you
believe social media platforms have
deepened American political polarization
well I'll tell you a couple of things
that that surprised me in the reporting
for this and this is why I wanted to do
the story the first thing is that while
I think
um I I would have said before I started
calling people that that the problem was
an echo chamber filter bubble epistemic
closure right was that oh we get on
social media and then we we somehow in
some way tend to assort with people who
have the same political and Views as we
do and then maybe the same cultural
abuses we do and we don't hear about
anything outside that and I think that
was fairly commonly accepted it turns
out that among social scientists it's
actually not the case social scientists
have not found evidence for that and as
one of them said to me like there's
there are worse Echo Chambers in in real
life you know IRL we tend to assort that
way and we don't turn into Political
freak Show you know in real life
particularly so if it's not filter
bubbles it's not an echo chamber
I would have said oh well obviously it's
the reverse right you would say oh it's
uh it's that you we go online and then
we're exposed to like repugnant views or
views that are repugnant to us and we
think oh those that that guy is terrible
like I don't want anything to do with
whatever that person is saying and
anything that they believe in any of the
stuff that they have in the background
of their you know chat window or
whatever but that doesn't happen either
when you actually do tests when
researchers do tests on this people
don't experience those kind of feelings
and we can talk about some of the
studies say in those experiences so the
question then is all right what happens
if we accept that polarization is
increasing and that does seem to be true
and if we accept that polarization is
something that's kind of independent of
like no some one political group
actually is saying repugnant thing like
objectively repugnant things and if we
accept that there are things that that
are weirdly
politicized but shouldn't be political
and you and I disagree with what those
things are but you could say something
like how does something like climate
change become political how does
something like what car you drive or
what if you drive a car or what your
favorite drink is whether it's alcoholic
or not how does those things become
political or polarizing and yet they do
so okay that's a long run up by way of
saying that this is a researcher he's a
computational social scientist and Peter
tornberg he's also trained as a
physicist and he's interested in
complexity Theory so the way that small
things turn into big things basically
and what he says is if you if you model
uh digitally people in a large Social
Network all it takes is really two
conditions to get real serious bad
polarization all you have to do first of
all is make sure that people are
connecting with with non-local
connections so that means strangers
people at a distance people they
wouldn't ordinarily connect with distant
from themselves both in in terms of
their demographic characteristics and
also literally like Geographic distance
and then you you kind of turn up our
tendency to distrust things that are
unfamiliar to us or the positive way to
say that is trust things that are
familiar
all you have to do is make those two
dials happen and you start to see the
the people of the little digital The
Sims inside this world begin to polarize
on things that are not just political
but things that are cultural as well
what researchers call affective
polarization it's very different than
ideological polarization or red blue
divide this is stuff like uh you know if
you drive an F-150 or a Prius things
that are that are choices that have
political components but are not
themselves political choices if you see
what I mean and that kind of that
effective polarization and the
demonization the attendant demonization
of people who are not in your
effectively polarized group are the
things that uh researchers worry the
most about it seems that context must
matter to some degree though because
there are situations that people find
themselves in where they encounter those
who at least
exist generally in very disparate places
they maybe come together for a
conference or for travel or whatever the
case would be so you can you can kind of
make that a reality uh and you can kind
of put these components together and
they don't seem to explode in the same
way that often takes place on social
media is that something about the
disinhibiting context of social media
that maybe is an additional Factor
yeah so that's a really good point all
of us have had the experience of being
of having a a perfectly Pleasant meal
with somebody who's political whose
political views you find are pregnant
obviously that has its limits if they're
somebody who wants to you know put you
in a camp maybe you don't want to be
sitting at the same dinner table with
them but but you see what I mean yes so
yes that context matters a lot
um and and there is the factor that
social media has an anonymizing effect
even if you have your real identity on
there you're at a distance it's a little
like just shouting at a television
screen and the television screen shouts
back you know but
um there's also the fact of the way the
social networks themselves work these
are these are by and large depending on
what you're on and what you're using
for-profit networks and and what they
depend on is our attention and
engagement because they're trying to use
our identities to sell ads against
and so in addition to the the factors
that tornberg came up with like how did
how does polarization happen in groups
who are exposed to each other in these
particular network with these particular
kinds of network effects the the social
networks themselves turn up their own
dial for um linking our identities to
our posts so they they ask you know who
you are essentially with everything that
you look at and everything that you post
and then privileging the loudest voices
because those get the most engagement
um and those tend to be the most extreme
so you know again we've all had the
experience of toodling Along on Twitter
or on Facebook and then seeing something
that was just astonishingly terrible
right and your first instinct is to want
to be like that's astonishingly terrible
which plays right into the way the the
economics of this thing work um and that
increases polarization right it
increases our our sense that everything
that we're doing has a political
component
there are some like for example Jonathan
height comes to mind who
has a sort of maybe different diagnosis
for what's going on than you but one of
his suggestions is
you can have an anonymous handle on
social media but the platform should
know exactly who you are so like for
example if I want to operate on Twitter
as you know Anonymous elephant 2655 I
can do that but when I create the
account I have to provide Twitter with
my driver's license or whatever proving
that I really am who I say I am and that
that would reduce the disinhibiting
nature of social media to some degree do
you agree with that
um
I have the there's a Hemingway line
isn't it pretty to think so I mean there
first of all I have concerns
look I'm not as much of an expert as as
Jonathan is but I have some concerns
about having identity be in escrow in
these for these for-profit companies as
well I don't I don't think that they're
trusted actors here I would say that
there are the internet could have gone a
very different way uh in the mid-2000s
let's say right where the companies that
turned into ad agencies effectively and
uh could have instead said we are going
to first of all create a way that to
build identity into the base layer of
the internet in the same way like the
Usenet and email we're built into the
base layer of the internet we forget I
think that Twitter and Facebook and
Google or websites they're fundamentally
they're just websites they're huge
they're complicated they're they're
they're they're vast they're
transnational but they're just websites
and what what what the people who
designed and built the internet chose
not to do because they chose a more a
profit-oriented motive was not was to
not build identity into that base layer
to not build ways for all of us to be
able to control our own identity in our
own self-expression on the internet and
this is something I sound uh I've I've
gone
um uh I've gone very like boing boing on
this I think
um to to say a thing like what was what
was supposed to happen was that we were
supposed to have tools to make it easy
to have a website an RSS feed and if you
want to have a what we used to call a
Blog and you now might call a sub stack
or medium or whatever if you want to
have that you can have that if you want
to sell stuff from your own little shop
here are some here's Machinery where you
can do that retailing and fulfillment
but instead we seeded all of that stuff
to these big transnational companies so
you know so I'm not sure that they're
they are not who I would trust to um to
be the Arbiters as we've seen to be good
Arbor good faith Arbiters of political
or other kinds of conversation online
although and so I'll I'll contradict
myself just very briefly and say the the
um I think another experience that has
become shared in common is we might all
have small uh you know DM chat groups
right like uh group chats or small
groups that were where you're in the DMS
on Twitter or Invitation Only very
tightly moderated groups on Facebook
those kind of smaller groups sometimes
Group by Affinity sometimes grouped by
social connections that are not on the
internet sometimes that are those become
very positive those are those are where
my meaningful social connections are at
this point in a way
um and sometimes they're arbited through
those through the big social networks
through Twitter or through a Facebook or
whatever and sometimes they're not but
the but because of their size and
because they are they are more tightly
controlled not for for
um like affective ideological engagement
but for some kind of emotional
engagement that's more meaningful they
tend to be more positive spaces when it
comes to you mentioned these these
companies platforms websites as the
Arbiters here
it seems pretty clear at this point that
the platforms generally benefit from the
entire way that they have operated
including boosting the voices that as
you talk about increase the polarization
loud voices Etc we kind of understand
that is it fair to say that because of
that they simply can't be counted on to
try to work on this problem is it that
flat out or are there ways to
incentivize Facebook and Twitter or
whoever
um to actually try to fix this problem
rather than profit from it yeah I don't
know that's that's such a good question
and we see it going on right right now I
mean that's the the that's at one of at
the heart of what is happening with Elon
Musk and Twitter for example right is is
is he's you know clearly interested in
in uh in elevating voices from the right
he's engaging with them himself
and so the question is well like how do
you deal with that if you know that a
lot of those voices are also you know
trolls are also gonna uh gonna
potentially hurt people you know send
out sort of stochastic terrorism against
trans people or against Jews or against
all the people who sort of are are the
like uh targets of the day you know
horribly so and and and so what are we
so the response to that has been like
essentially weirdly to me let the market
deal with it right well he's going to
lose all his advertisers if he does that
that's sort of our response and and that
may happen right that could or the
advertisers could then pressure him and
say you can't do that or we won't
advertise so it becomes the what we
trust as a society is that the the same
profit motives that got us here will get
us out and uh you know that's the thing
that we could all perhaps be polarized
online about whether we believe will
happen or not yeah I mean I guess I
would say I'm depressed I don't have
solid evidence to think that that's
exactly the way it would work absent
some kind of uh countervailing Force but
probably a conversation for for for the
next conversation uh we've been speaking
with Adam Rogers who's a senior Tech
correspondent at Insider also author of
the book full spectrum and we're going
to link to the article that's been the
source for today's conversation Adam
really appreciate your time today thank
you
my pleasure thanks for having me
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show a new
report from inside failed former
president Donald Trump's Inner Circle
shows that Donald Trump is now furious
with Kanye West and is claiming that
West tried to F him this is going from
crazy to even crazier and it all relates
to this white supremacist dinner as it
is now being called think of that term
now being part of the the news cycle for
days Trump's white supremacist dinner
now the subject and triggering fact
actor for his ire against Kanye West as
well as Nick Fuentes and others article
from NBC News lays it out quite
interestingly the article is called the
inside story of Trump's explosive dinner
with yea and Nick Fuentes what was
supposed to be a private dinner ended up
being a political nightmare now I want
to be clear and make sure people know
some of the things that are in this
article which seems well enough Source
let's put it that way
are being denied by Nick Fuentes but I
actually believe that that doesn't mean
that much because Fuentes may not even
be privy to some of what is here the
narrative is compelling I encourage you
to read it and we're linking to it it's
by Mark Caputo and it says just two days
before Thanksgiving Trump was planning
to have a private uneventful dinner with
an old friend yay the rapper formerly
known as Kanye West they arranged to
have dinner Tuesday night at Mar-A-Lago
after some phone conversations but Trump
may have been walking into a trap Trump
has said he didn't know Fuentes the
white nationalist and anti-semite or his
background that West said hey he wants
to come in and have dinner with us as
well there is a damage control campaign
now being put together that the NBC news
article explains but the most
interesting part of this comes under
this section the master got trolled the
headline grabbing attention on his
guests and therefore the subsequent
Fallout were all but insured by Trump
before the dinner when he made a grand
entrance at 8 pm on November 22nd
understand that at Mar-A-Lago there's a
table reserved for Trump and his guests
it's in full view of everybody so it can
have all the Pomp and Circumstance that
a narcissist like Donald Trump would
want
so there was no question that everybody
was going to see who was there but it
ended up not being a happy photo op yay
criticized Trump for not doing enough to
help the Trump rioters he told Trump he
might run for president and that Trump
should be his running mate which
infuriated Trump reportedly who then
attacked Kim Kardashian yay's ex-wife
yea later put out a video saying Trump
is really impressed with Nick Fuentes
Fuentes says he praised Trump as my hero
and criticized DeSantis and then the
advisor that spoke to NBC characterizes
the entire thing as the master troll got
trolled Kanye punked Trump and there is
a section about Milo yiannopoulos who I
believe may have actually really been
the orchestrator of this entire thing
and the most interesting paragraph maybe
of the article
Trump fumed afterward that yea had
betrayed him by ambushing him quote he
tried to F me he's crazy he can't beat
me Trump said according to one Confidant
who then relayed the conversation to NBC
News Trump was totally blindsided The
Source said it was a setup
supposedly summoned Trump's orbit warned
him don't have dinner with Kanye who's
already Under Fire for anti-Semitism the
inclusion of Fuentes making it all the
more volatile so first of all none of
this is the picture of stability Kanye
is not stable Trump is certainly not
stable nobody involved in this thing is
even remotely stable now Nick Fuentes is
denying that this was overtly a setup
but the truth is that Fuentes may have
simply been a pawn in the setup rather
than a participant for all we know this
sort of thing has Milo yiannopoulos's
fingerprints all over it quite frankly
and as you know I've been in touch with
Milo over the years it's been years
since he agreed to come on the program
multiple times I've invited Milo to come
on he has rejected the offer he's
welcome to come on anytime and I would
love to talk to him about this but
there's a few different things that are
important to understand one seemingly
nothing is below the Office of the
President at this point in time okay
consider how much American politics has
changed in 2004 Democratic
um uh primary candidate for president
Howard Dean screamed about we're gonna
go to Iowa you know he made a noise he
screamed it ended his campaign
it seems so quaint at this point in time
where Trump is having Kanye West at
dinner and he's surprised that Kanye is
even crazier and then Kanye has a white
nationalist in tow and Milo yiannopoulos
is involved and they they're having this
dinner in a public setting where
everybody could see so politics has
changed dramatically in the United
States that's for sure and by the way
imagine being Trump and ending up
surprise that Kanye is even crazier than
you are like it's sort of like a race to
the bottom here that's going on so who
set up whom it's not completely clear at
this point in time but what does seem
very clear
is that you know Trump never had a great
team around him his 2016 team wasn't a
great team they did end up getting him
elected when we have to give them credit
for that Trump's 2020 team was even
worse they failed to get him elected I
don't know who's around Trump at this
point in time for what is a very early
start to his 2024 campaign but either
it's a disastrous team or Trump simply
doesn't listen to them which would be
pretty on brand with what we've learned
about Donald Trump wacky wacky times and
I don't think these types of stories are
going to go away and we have to devote
just a couple of minutes to the
continued middle of the night rantings
from Donald Trump let's talk about that
momentarily
at 1 30 in the morning this morning or
last night you know or very early this
morning once again Donald Trump took not
to Twitter where he is now unbanned but
to his own platform truth social truth
essential and once again he started
ranting and raving
the level of instability that these
rants are projecting is really something
else and it seems that with every bad
news cycle the most recent one being
this entire Kanye white nationalist Nick
Fuentes dinner Trump goes more and more
Bonkers on Troth Central there's always
a Feeling
of sort of like what is he going to
become obsessed with next and at 1 30 in
the morning Trump started by re-trothing
his own earlier truth saying quote Rhino
Carl Rove is a Fox News loser A pompous
fool with bad political instincts in
other words he loses a lot only good at
taking people's money and wasting it I
was 12-0 against him in Senate
endorsements not something I'm proud of
but something people especially
candidates should know
Trump then continuing with another one
of his fixations his endorsement record
also 12-0 in Senate endorsements against
the broken Old Crow Mitch McConnell who
is by the way a six percent approval
rating not exactly great news for the
Republican party now I don't know
exactly what he's talking about there
um you know Mehmet Oz lost it seems
that's at least one in Trump's loss
column it's always very confusing and
he's sort of like the the the Trump will
often limit his endorsement record to
for example like endorsements made on
even days of the month when it was sunny
among that group he's 4-0 for example
you know it's sort of like with baseball
statistics Trump continuing this morning
quote the Manhattan DA's office has not
tried a murder case since 2015 despite
the fact that violent crime in New York
City is at an all-time high remember a
violent crime is higher in Oklahoma City
than it is in New York City Trump
continuing that six years ago and yet
after by the way it's not six years ago
it's almost eight but okay but maybe
math not his strong suit that's six
years ago and yet after years of
Investigation millions of dollars spent
and the costly and laborious inspection
of almost 10 million pages of documents
we are in the second week of a fringe
benefits case over an executive's use of
a company car a company apartment and
his grandchildren's education no such
case has ever been tried before said
this is Trump Furious that his former
CFO
is in legal trouble because of things
that he did quite frankly Trump then
continuing on the crime spree as we
might call it saying quote mothers and
families of victims of violent crime
and by the way mothers is with an
apostrophe it's just crazy mothers and
families of victims of violent crime
which is breaking all capital r records
in New York City are Furious that the
criminals who killed their loved ones
haven't been given a trial in many years
while millions of dollars and years of
work has been spent on a ridiculous
Fringe Benefits case the likes of which
has never been prosecuted before in our
Capital C counties history I think he
means country it is a continuation of
the greatest Capital Witch Hunt of all
time the DA's office should focus on
capital M murders that's not lowercase M
murders it's capital M and violent crime
not BS and then lastly and as you might
see Trump's grammar and spelling
degenerating the longer this rant
continues quote despite producing tens
of thousands of jobs in such important
and Lasting structures in New York City
it is said that I will never be able to
get a fair trial there now it's unclear
whether Trump means it is sad
or whether he is saying other people are
saying it's just all so unclear well we
will soon see because this case against
two companies is a disgrace that should
never have been brought and has been
totally disproven even prosecutors quit
the DA's office because they thought it
was unfair now that's a lie prosecutors
quit the DA's office because they
realized we're doing all this work
investigating Trump and he's not going
to be prosecuted they're not going to
indict him and our work is for nothing
that's why they quit one last line from
Trump here such a case has never even
been brought exclamation point before
period I've never seen grammar like this
before Justice in America
this man is unhinged ladies and
gentlemen I I have not ever seen we've
never seen any president do the things
Donald Trump has done these types of
randomly capitalized
uh misgamored stream of Consciousness
sentence fragments and run on sentences
you see both sentence fragments and run
on sentences
we've never seen anything like this from
any president and the humiliation
continues to grow I think if we want to
find a silver lining here the Silver
Lining is because Trump is posting this
stuff to Troth Central rather than to
Twitter
fewer people are seeing it we have a
voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here is a trumpist caller
who is furious and is warning me my
Judgment Day is coming
mentally ill well that's their
prerogative
74 million people are mentally ill no
remember I didn't say 74 million people
are mentally ill
we have talked with cult experts and
mental health experts
there are some trumpists
who are just selfish people but they are
what we would call Sane they saw Trump's
policies as being good for them
personally financially that's one group
there's another group of people who are
simply brainwashed those are more like
the cult people they're not mentally ill
in the sense we normally mean they're
just brainwashed
there's another group that's just
ignorant they've fallen for lies that
they don't know are lies and then yes
there's a group that's mentally ill
we've interviewed some of them at the
rallies but I've never said 74 million
people who voted for Trump or mentally
ill criticize me for things I've said
please is that what it is pal
you know what when you stand before your
maker at the end on Judgment Day yeah
you're going to be one sorry dude I
understand me boy the election was
stolen heating fraud you name it human
rats demon rack
I guess he stays on the phone for a
while I don't know if you can hear the
static
sounds like a car drove by
well listen when I stand before and face
Judgment at the end maybe I will be
sorry we'll have to wait and see if that
happens but uh the election was not
stolen Donald Trump genuinely lost
that's it we've got a great bonus show
for you today Republicans with unlimited
sick days are voting against time off
for rail workers we'll tell you what's
going on uh parents have refused the use
of vaccinated blood the blood from a
vaccinated person for a life-saving
surgery for their baby
oh boy
and an Iranian man was shot dead for
celebrating that Iran lost a World Cup
game to the United States all of those
stories and many more on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money but everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad sign up
at joinpakman.com we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC